what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and in the DC World a lot is going on
right now and James Gunn has told us
that this month of January 2023 we are
going to get an update on what DC has
planned or specifically what James Gunn
and Peter Safran have planned for DC we
know it's going to be a reboot although
kind of a soft reboot but the main
Justice League characters are out of
here only some side characters are going
to remain that and some main characters
like Peacemaker but fans have been
wondering what announcements we should
be expecting from the DCU and which
characters are going to be entering
their new universe and James Gunn has
recently stated in a response to a
comment on Instagram that although yes
they have the next 8 to 10 years planned
out for the DCU they're not going to
announce all of that this month only the
first chapter which I'm assuming is just
like an MCU phase and fans are really
hoping for some awesome characters to be
announced for this chapter of the new
DCU and one of them could be the Green
Lantern and and the Green Lantern might
actually be played by Chris Pratt now
this confirmation comes after James Gunn
basically confirmed on Twitter that the
cast of The Guardians of the Galaxy over
at Marvel Studios was most likely going
to join him in a project or multiple
projects over in the DCU he said he
loves the cast he works really close
with them and he knows he'll be working
with them again and he said most likely
over at DC and he specifically mentioned
Chris Pratt now here's the thing James
Gunn not too long ago about a month ago
talked about the Green Lantern and how
he was going to be included in the new
DCU and that he is indeed going to be a
very important character and should be
treated as an important character now
personally I actually think Chris Pratt
would do a really good job as the Green
Lantern but the question is which
version would he play would he play Hal
Jordan or could he play Guy Gardner now
I think he could play both but Guy
Gardner is known for being you know
witty he's arrogant he cracks a lot of
jokes he's pretty abrasive in fact in
all honesty perhaps Ryan Reynolds should
have actually played Guy Gardner the way
he plays Deadpool kind of would have
worked for Guy Gardner but Chris Pratt
also has this humor many people love the
Guardians of the Galaxy and specifically
Star-Lord his character because it does
have the serious tones but of course
it's also really funny now of course he
could play Hal Jordan there's no reason
that he couldn't it's not like he's a
dud or anything like that in fact I
could see Chris Pratt playing the Green
Lantern like he is in the animated
version and after all how is typically
the most famous Green Lantern and if
James Gunn is doing a reboot of the DCU
and we are going to include the Green
Lantern it makes sense that he would
want that version to be how and as we
all know James Gunn loves his not so
famous superheroes so this very well
could be a possibility now of course
there are other characters that Chris
Pratt could play in the DC Universe but
all eyes are looking at the Green
Lantern for now since James Gunn talked
about how important the Green Lantern
was going to be and he said that Chris
Pratt was probably going to join him
over a d see I think it would be cool
but let us know your thoughts about this
in the comments down below do you want
this do you not want this let us know
why don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest DC news for live updates you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf